me and Sarah have both watched Insidious
the red door and we both had different
interpretations of the end so there are
going to be spoilers for this part Sarah
what was your interpretation of Elisa's
appearance at the end of the movie the
appearance of Elise just confused me
quite a lot I felt like the YouTube
video made sense the ending to me made
me feel like there was something going
on with Josh that he was either dead or
trapped in the further because when we
see Elise she says two lines that are a
call back to earlier in the film she
repeats a line that Carl said at the
funeral of death floods the mind with
memories she says that just in a
different way and she also repeats a
line she said in the YouTube video about
when you're in the further you need to
keep a steady stride and she again says
that to Josh which just made me think
he's not back in the real world that's
interesting I'm definitely gonna have to
be looking out for that next time I
watch the movie I just kind of assumed
that it was like a crappy we need to get
at least in here somehow and they didn't
really think it through yeah
let us know in the comments on what your
interpretation is